auch heute wieder ein wunderbarer tag
herrlichstem sommerwetter hitze
eigentlich das heißeste jahr seit
jahrzehnten haben wir in diesem jahr das
hatten wir auch schattenseiten ja
ständig immer wieder brechen feuer aus
auch hier bei uns in deutschland knapp
eine woche nach ausbruch des feuers auf
dem sprengplatz im berliner grunewald da
ist allerdings die sperrung der
stadtautobahn avus nun endlich wieder
aufgehoben worden heißt aufatmen die
hauptstadt dass ich den rest der
menschen in deutschland egal aber
tatsächlich ist das nur um eine
dimension klappen eine der wichtigsten
dann sozusagen in die stadt rein
verkehrsader die war jetzt die ganze
zeit gesperrt riesenchaos immer wieder
war es zu unkontrollierten explosionen
auf diesen sprengplatz im grunewald
gekommen ja unseren bild reportern ist
es allerdings nun gelungen einen der
lösch roboter in dieses hochgefährliche
gebiet zu begleiten die bilder zeigen
hier ist
bild in der verbotenen zone im grunewald
herrscht auch gut eine woche nach den
brennt nun explosionen immer noch große
alarmbereitschaft beim reinkommen in den
550 meter stärk kreis ist nur mit
gepanzerten fahrzeugen möglich denn jede
sekunde könnte es knallt
mitten im grunewald befindet sich das
lager der polizei hof und bomben
munition aufbewahrt werden tagelang
erschütterten explosionen das gebiet
brennende breiten sich aus können kaum
unter kontrolle gebracht werden
beim betreten des sperrgebiets erklärt
die feuerwehr man darf niemals und unter
keinen umständen die wege verlassen es
bleibt brandgefährlich
seit dienstagabend sind auch
hubschrauber der bundespolizei im
einsatz im minuten-takt werfen sie 2000
liter wasser über dem sperrgebiet ab
vereinzelt steigen doch auch wolken auf
es bleibt immer noch gefährlich deshalb
kommt zunehmend technik zum einsatz
seines roboter kreuzen die geräumten
wege
auch im einsatz der bergepanzer t 55
sowjetischer bauart aus sachsen-anhalt
er soll dafür sorgen dass sich flammen
nicht weiter ausbreiten können
zwischen noch gesunden bäumen sieht man
vor allem verkohlte baumstümpfe der
boden ist abgebrannt auch gesunde bäume
werden sterben erklärt das forstamt
ohnewald
das bild reporter team darf bis auf etwa
300 meter an den springplatz rang ab da
herrscht striktes fotografier und
filmverbot
denn jede aufnahme könnte den waldbrand
und explosionen wieder lostreten
für die einsatzkräfte zählt nur eins
schadensbegrenzung im wald der mit aus
bislang 50 hektar nicht 320 werden
[Musik]